You've just written a program that contains multiple question types. Over here,
we have a plain question, over here a choice question. We pass each of them to
the present question method, that method is down here. It has a parameter of
type question. And now let's focus on this display method here. Notice that q
is of type Question. And I would like you to tell me exactly which display
method is called, in the call q.display. Is it always, the display of the
question class? Is it always the display method of the choice question class?
Does it vary? Is it sometimes question display and sometimes choice question
display? Or could this call even call some other method, something other than
question display and choice question display. Let me know what you think.